wir sind live mit ZDF heute live schönen
guten Morgen wobei ob dieser morgen für
jeden so gut ist das ist eben die Frage
um Mitternacht ist der Warnstreik im
Verkehrsbereich angelaufen einer der
größten seit vielen Jahren das heißt in
Deutschland steht heute sehr sehr viel
still
seit heute Nacht um 0 Uhr stehen
bundesweit Busse und Bahn still die
Gewerkschaften Verdi und EVG haben zum
ersten Mal gemeinsam zu einem
24-stündigen Bahnstreik aufgerufen
betroffen sind der gesamte Fernverkehr
der Deutschen Bahn aber auch Flughäfen
Autobahntunnel und der Schiffsverkehr
der öffentliche Nahverkehr wird in
sieben Bundesländern bestreicht
für Schülerinnen und Schüler die nicht
zur Schule kommen können wurde in
einigen Bundesländern die Präsenzpflicht
aufgehoben auch am Dienstag kann es
wegen Nachwirkungen des Streiks noch zu
zahlreichen Ausfällen bei der Bahn
kommen
ja und das wollen wir uns genauer
anschauen deshalb sprechen wir gleich
mit der Expertin für Streikrecht Lena
Rutkowski darüber ob dieser Streik
angemessen ist und welche Rechte man
überhaupt hat wenn man betroffen ist
diw-präsident Marcel Fratscher wird mit
uns gleich durchgehen worum es bei
diesem Streik überhaupt geht und warum
er so eskaliert wir sammeln eure
Statements und eure Fragen und geben Sie
dann gerne weiter bitte in die Chat
schreiben oder an die E-Mail-Adresse
schicken die jetzt gleich eingeblendet
wird wir haben auf Youtube die Community
gefragt ob sie denn überhaupt noch
Verständnis für den Streik hat wir
können uns das mal kurz anschauen hier
also die Frage war habt ihr Verständnis
für den geplanten Streik und da sagen 65
Prozent immerhin noch ja und 35 Prozent
sagen nein also eine eine Argument zum
Beispiel für den Streik hat Holger
geschrieben es ist auch ein Streik für
mehr Gesundheit und Work-Life-Balance
und gegen zunehmende
belastungsdepressionen volle Solidarität
oder Saskia sagt es müssen viel mehr
streiken vor allem im linken Sektor aber
gerade dort tun es die Menschen am
allerwenigsten javira ähm würden diese
Leute eine faire Entlohnung und gute
Arbeitsbedingungen haben müssen sie
nicht streiken heißt mein Frust und
Ärger richten sich gegen Arbeitgeber und
Gesetzgeber nicht gegen die Menschen die
ihn unhaltbaren Zuständen Arbeiten es
gibt aber auch Leute die haben
mittlerweile vom Streit die Nase voll
z.B Bad Kitty ich habe Verständnis dafür
dass gestreikt wird nicht jedoch dafür
dass es ist diejenigen trifft die am
wenigsten was dafür können den
Arbeitgebern ist es doch größtenteils
egal das gestreikt wird leidtragender
sind die ganzen Menschen die an dem Tag
nicht oder zu spät zur Arbeit kommen und
abgemahnt werden oder Ihren Flug
verpassen das findet sie wirklich nicht
fair oder Saba schreibt es geht um eine
Lohnerhöhung von 10,5% des halte ich für
übertrieben ist kurbelt die
inflationsspirale weiter an ja all das
werden wir besprechen und jetzt schalten
wir erstmal nach draußen und gucken was
da überhaupt abgeht wir gehen zu unseren
Reportern Peter Thyssen und Thomas
münden sie sind heute morgen unterwegs
schönen guten Morgen euch
du stehst am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof
wie ist die Situation bei euch
ja wie man sieht ist hier so gut wie
nichts los am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof
wird diesen Ort an einem normalen
Werktag kennt der würde sich verwundert
die Augen reiben wenn er hierher käme
wenn er nichts von diesem Streik wüsste
normalerweise fahren hier so um die 1000
Züge pro Tag ein und befördern fast eine
halbe Million Menschen darunter sehr
viele Pendler mit 400.000 Pendlern ist
Frankfurt eine der Pendler Hauptstädte
Deutschlands man kann sich also ausmalen
was es bedeutet wenn weder Züge noch
Straßenbahnen hier fahren
ich fahre heute morgen hier unterwegs
und habe sehr viele Taxis auf den
Straßen gesehen viele Menschen arbeiten
im Homeoffice aber viele müssen halt
dann doch zu ihrem Arbeitsplatz gelang
davon profitieren die Taxis zumindest
die funktaxis hier am Taxistand draußen
vor der Tür hingegen stehen viele Taxis
und die Fahrer haben nichts zu tun sie
warten vergeblich auf Passagiere die
normalerweise hier aus den Zügen
aussteigen und dann weiter befördert
werden viel los ist hier bei den
Fernbussen ich habe eben einen Bus
gesehen der nach Amsterdam ging die
fernbusunternehmen haben auch versucht
ihre Kapazitäten zu erhöhen mehr Fahrer
in der in der Schnelle der Zeit hierher
zu bekommen mehr Busse aber natürlich
sind da auch den Kapazitäten ihre
natürlichen Grenzen gesetzt ja bei dir
im Hintergrund sieht man Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhof gerne in der Lehre nichts
los wir müssen uns immer zur verfolgen
führen es ist Montagmorgen also
normalerweise ist morgens da um die
Uhrzeit richtig viel los hast du denn
Betroffene sprechen können wie sind die
drauf gibt's da noch Verständnis für den
Streik
ja sind natürlich sehr wenige Menschen
hergekommen fast alle wussten ja dass
heute Streik ist tatsächlich habe ich
aber den ein oder anderen heute morgen
hier angetroffen der nichts von dem
Streik erfahren hat ein junger Mann der
nach Darmstadt fahren wollte und ganz
verwundert war dass kein Zug geht der
hat jetzt überlegt wie komme ich dahin
wahrscheinlich mit dem Taxi das wird
aber eine Menge Geld kosten eine andere
Frau habe ich getroffen die kein
Verständnis für den Streik geäußert hat
das Stimmungsbild ist so ein bisschen
wie in der Gesamtbevölkerung die
Umfragen zeigen ja eine Mehrheit der
Deutschen befürwortet den Streik oder
die Forderung der Gewerkschaften doch
eine stattliche Minderheit in den ab als
überzogen vielleicht können wir mal
direkt nachfragen bei einem der
Verhandlungsführer von den
Gewerkschaften Hannover ist bei mir er
ist Verhandlungsführer für die EVG sie
haben es gerade gehört hallo roch viele
Menschen haben Verständnis für den
Streik aber sehr viele Leben Ihnen auch
ab sie sagen sie können doch nicht das
ganze Land lahmlegen was sagen sie denen
ja das deutlich wird aufgrund der
Situation in der wir uns jetzt befinden
auch für diese Menschen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern wie wichtig unsere Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sind um den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr und auch den Fernverkehr
überhaupt zu realisieren dass jeden Tag
das auch während Corona und dass wir
jetzt hier stehen und nur deshalb nichts
passiert weil die Arbeitgeberinnen und
Arbeitgeber nicht in der Lage gewesen
sind und verhandlungsfähiger Angebote
für unsere Kolleginnen und Kollegen
vorzulegen dass wir eben das was so
wichtig ist den öffentlichen Nahverkehr
und auch den Fernverkehr auch für die
Zukunft möglichst gut aufrecht zu halten
und auch noch zu steigern jetzt haben
sie eine Forderung aufgestellt 12,5%
mehr Lohn bzw eine eine Steigerung
mindestens 650 Euro das ist ja doch eine
wahnsinnig hohe Forderung weit über dem
der zu erwartenden Inflation in diesem
Jahr ist das nicht doch sehr überzogen
was sie da fordern ja man muss das
Gesamtbild sich anschauen unsere
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der Bahn und
Busbranche haben während Corona
lohntarif Zurückhaltung gezeigt also das
heißt wir haben dort ein sehr sehr
geringen Abschluss gemacht dafür
Arbeitsplatzsicherheit hergestellt mit
den Arbeitgeberinnen und Arbeitgebern
das fehlt den Menschen heute dazu kommt
das Thema was Sie angesprochen haben
Inflation und dazu kommt ein ganz
wesentliches Thema und das ist nicht
Krisen gemacht das ist ein Thema was wir
uns in der Republik über Jahre
vielleicht sogar Jahrzehnte selber
geschaffen haben Personal und
Fachkräftemangel und das hat ganz
wesentlich was damit zu tun dass die
Menschen zu schlecht bezahlt werden und
das nicht nur in unserer Branche sondern
auch bei den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von Verdi aber so ein Streik wie heute
ist noch nie da gewesen in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik viele
fürchten jetzt dass wir französische
Verhältnisse bekommen in Frankreich wird
ja viel öfter und intensiver gestreikt
als hier in Deutschland also haben sie
nicht doch die Befürchtung dass sie
damit so ein bisschen den sozialen
Frieden in Deutschland auch aufs Spiel
setzen mit seinem riesigen Streik nein
das glaube ich nicht ich glaube das ist
für die Bevölkerung eher wichtig ist zu
sehen dass wir das sehr konzentriert tun
und dass wir das nicht über drei Tage im
schlimmsten Fall nacheinander tun
sondern dass wir das hier als die Gebete
Gewerkschaften gemeinsam tun und
gemeinsam Anzeichen für die Branche zu
setzen hat Buß und B glaube ich dass man
auch die politische Dimension die in
Frankreich gerade eine Rolle spielt
nicht mit der in unserer Republik
vergleichen kann die Arbeitgeber warfen
ihnen vor dass sie streiken ohne zu
verhandeln sie wollen erst Ende April
glaube ich an den Verhandlungstisch
zurückkehren warum so spät warum starten
Sie nicht sofort wieder Verhandlungen
mit den Arbeitgebern wir sind in der
zweiten Runde bzw beginnen jetzt im
Bälde mit der zweiten Runde Ende des
Monats das bezieht sich aber vor allen
Dingen auf die anderen Unternehmen nicht
db-unternehmen mit denen wir jetzt die
zweite Runde beginnen werden die DBAG
hat in zwei Verhandlungsrunden die
Chance gehabt mit uns in Verhandlung
einzutreten und in der ersten Runde hat
sie gar kein Angebot vorgelegt und in
der zweiten Runde ein
zweieinhalb-seitiges Papier mit zehn
Punkten davon waren fünf Punkte
Gegenforderung und fünf Punkte haben
unsere Forderung gerade mal gestritten
das heißt sie bleiben hart wie könnte
das Weitergehen aus ihrer Sicht das ist
relativ einfach es müssen
verhandlungsfähiger Angebote auf den
Tisch dann setzt man sich zusammen und
dann kann man auch reden und wenn nicht
wenn nicht wird es eine weitere Stufe
der Eskalation geben aber nicht
ausgelöst durch uns die die für ihre
Löhne kämpfen sondern durch die die
nichts vorlegen
ja es ist zu spüren die Fronten sind
tatsächlich haben ja ganz lieben Dank
Peter Theisen vielen Dank auch für
dieses Interview und wir schalten dann
später im Laufe dieses Streams noch mal
an den Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof vielen
Dank für den Moment wir wollen jetzt
weitergehen zu Thomas münden
Thomas schönen guten Morgen du stehst an
einer
Fußgängerbrücke über der A40 in Essen ja
Film bleibt heute morgen gar nichts
anderes übrig als mit dem Auto zur
Arbeit zu fahren wie ist die Situation
bei euch
die Situation ist tatsächlich so wie sie
vorausgesagt war es gibt Stau ohne Ende
die A40 ist die Lebensader des
Ruhrgebiets geht einmal quer durch das
Ruhrgebiet als Verkehrsknoten Punkt oder
das Ballungsraum schrammt jeden Morgen
am Verkehrschaos entlang aber heute
morgen ist es tatsächlich perfekt wenn
wir hier mal hinter uns schauen das
sieht so schon seit anderthalb Stunden
aus wir haben vier Kilometer von
Duisburg bis Essen 4 Kilometer von Essen
bis Bochum das setzt sich nahtlos fort
auf der A3 die zweite wichtige Autobahn
stehen schon acht Kilometer zwischen
Oberhausen und stärker gerade in der
städtisch stauen sich die Fahrzeuge auf
den Zugfahrten zur Autobahn also es ist
schon sehr chaotisch und die meisten die
eben auf das Auto setzen müssen werden
erstmal eine Stunde lang im Stau stehen
ich habe ein paar Autofahrern gesprochen
die sagten irgendwie ich fahre nach
Bochum ich muss nach Bochum das dauert
normalerweise 20 Minuten heute habe ich
meine Stunde eingeplant und wer weiß ob
das reicht also man muss sagen es ist
schon ordentlich was los auf den Straßen
und mitten in diesem ganzen großen Chaos
fährt eine das einzige Buslinie die
Essen und Mülheim zwei Städte
miteinander verbindet ein Nachtexpress
den konnte die ruhrbahn der Veranstalter
hier Aufrechterhalten der kommt aber nur
einmal pro Stunde und das ist natürlich
für so ein Ruhrgebiet ein Tropfen auf
den heißen Steinen also James schreibt
uns auf Youtube dass er zwei Stunden von
Bochum nach Essen gebraucht hat also für
14 km ich glaube der ist für heute
bedient und braucht nichts mehr aber wie
ist denn die Situation am heute morgen
die
Autobahngesellschaft die streikt ja auch
welche Auswirkungen hat das
das ist eine gute Frage man weiß es gar
nicht so ganz genau also die
Autobahngesellschaft ist der zuständig
dafür wenn irgendwo Pannen auftreten
wenn irgendwas repariert werden muss
eine Signalisierung ausfällt oder sowas
das eben dann vor Ort zu reparieren dazu
geht auch um die Verkehrslenkung das
sind diese Brücken die mit den
Geschwindigkeiten über der Autobahn
bestückt werden solange das alles läuft
ist das völlig in Ordnung da passiert
gar nichts aber was passiert wenn es zu
irgendeine kommt dann muss repariert
werden wobei die Autobahn Gesellschaft
sagt wir bekommen das erst einmal hin
ganz abstrakt könnte es aber natürlich
dazu kommen wenn man es eben nicht
hinbekommt das irgendwelche größeren
Tunnel gesperrt werden müssen das könnte
sein der Tunnel bei Köln das könnte
natürlich auch ganzen bundesweit andere
Tunnel sein aber dann würde es natürlich
dazu kommen dass man im Endeffekt eine
Autobahn komplett sperren muss weil man
im Tunnel die Sicherheit nicht
garantieren kann und das ist dann schon
eine weitere Stufe der Eskalation denn
auf allen Autobahnen im Bundesgebiet
denke ich ist heute morgen ein bisschen
mehr los als normal
und dann wäre der eine oder andere
Verkehr dann auch sicher kurz vor dem
Kollaps wie ist es denn die Leute mit
denen du heute morgen gesprochen hast
haben die noch Verständnis oder sagen
die mittlerweile jetzt habe ich so die
Nase voll von den ganzen Einschränkungen
es ist schon so dass die meisten
tatsächlich immer noch sagen wir haben
Verständnis viele sagen wir sehen ja
selber die hohe Inflation wir sehen
alles ist teurer geworden und wir sehen
das gerade in den Niedriglohnsektoren
die Leute natürlich weniger verdienen
und sagen wir mal ordentlichen Schluck
aus der Pulle wie man hier im Ruhrgebiet
sagen würde brauchen aber es ist
natürlich schon noch so wir hatten eben
so eine Montage Crew die hier an uns
vorbei fuhr die saßen zu zweit im Auto
vier Plätze waren Lehrer der sagt ich
muss jetzt alle Leute abholen und wer
lange wer weiß wie lange das dauert und
das bringt mir den Plan nicht für heute
durcheinander sondern für die ganze
Woche und er war schon ein bisschen
geladen ansonsten neben dir das im
Moment noch sehr gelassen die Frage ist
halt wie geht das weiter wenn es jetzt
wieder nicht zu einer Einigung kommt
wenn es jetzt noch mehr Streit gibt wenn
sich das Ganze fortsetzt irgendwann
werden die Leute natürlich ein bisschen
genervter werden aber im Moment sind
alle noch der Meinung Streik muss sein
über die Forderung habe ich auch gehört
kann man über die Höhe der Forderung
kann man streiten aber das ist mehr sein
muss als das von dem die Rede war das
ist bei vielen trifft das durchaus
Zustimmung
und kann man tatsächlich sagen momentan
dass ich viele doch auf diesen Morgen
ganz gut vorbereitet haben
mein Eindruck ich habe jetzt auch ein
bisschen rumgeguckt ich bin eben auch am
Duisburger Hauptbahnhof mal kurz gewesen
ja also an den Bahnhöfen ist es leer
hier stehen jetzt auch keine verirrten
Menschen die auf irgendwelche
Straßenbahnen oder Busse warten und die
Leute sind relativ gelassen viele haben
auch gesagt ich wäre gerne zu Hause
geblieben
Home Office ging aber jetzt gerade heute
nicht aber viele sind wahrscheinlich
auch im Homeoffice aber wir sehen immer
hinter mir schauen das steht fast das
ist eine Geschwindigkeit von 10 km auf
einer Strecke von ich würde mal
geschätzt sagen 12 bis 15 km mitten
durch die Essener Innenstadt und das
wird in den anderen Innenstädten nicht
anders aussehen also es ist schon eine
Aufgabe für Autofahrer heute morgen von
A nach B zu kommen und viele werden froh
wenn dann doch Bus und Bahn fahren
würden alles klar Thomas münden vielen
Dank
tschüss
ja also tatsächlich Marina Mensch
schreibt zum Beispiel auf Facebook kein
Wunder dass immer mehr Menschen sauer
sind bei der Inflation überall
Reallohnverlust Kaufkraftverlust und
wachsendes Armutsrisiko wir haben jetzt
einen Überblick wie es draußen ausschaut
und über genau diese Themen wollen wir
jetzt sprechen und damit kommen wir zu
Marcel fratcher vom Deutschen Institut
für Wirtschaftsforschung wie gesagt
schickt gerne eure Fragen oder
Statements ich leite die gerne weiter
guten Morgen Herr fratsche hallo guten
Morgen bevor wir reden in wenigen
Sekunden schauen wir uns noch mal kurz
an wie denn die Forderungen auf den
Punkt gebracht und zusammengefasst sind
die Positionen im Tarifkonflikt liegen
auseinander für den öffentlichen Dienst
fordert Verdi 10,5% mehr Lohn mindestens
aber 500 €. die Arbeitgeber bieten bei
längerer Laufzeit 5% in zwei Schritten
einen Inflationsausgleich von 2500 € in
zwei Schritten und eine Anhebung der
Jahresende Zahlung
ja Vater haben wir die Forderung noch
mal auf den Punkt zusammengefasst ähm
klären wir es direkt am Anfang halten
Sie die für gerechtfertigt
die Forderung ist gerechtfertigt wenn
man sich die Inflation anschaut 8% 2022
in diesem Jahr vermutlich noch mal um
die 6%. das heißt Ende des Jahres werden
die Menschen 14 Prozent weniger
Kaufkraft mit ihren bestehenden Löhnen
haben
10,5% Lohnforderungen selbst wenn sich
Verdi durchsetzen würde würde das ja
immer noch ein reale und Verlust
bedeuten also die Menschen wird immer
noch in Wohlstand einschränken und wir
dürfen nicht vergessen der Staat gehört
zu den großen Gewinnern der Inflation
wenn sie in den Supermarkt gehen 20 25%
mehr für ihre Lebensmittel bezahlen
müssen dann kassiert der Staat ja mit
über die Mehrwertsteuer und das geht für
viele andere Bereiche auch deshalb ja
also wenn jemand diese hören Kosten
stemmen kann dann ist es der Staat es
ist richtig nicht jede Kommune kann das
geht also um die Verteilung der Gelder
aber erst einmal muss man festhalten
diese Forderung liegt weit unter der
Entwertung der Kaufkraft der Löhne
und damit haben sie die erste Frage von
Karim schon beantwortet der eben gefragt
hat wie realistisch diese Forderungen
sind seine zweite Frage ist ähm können
dass die Arbeitgeber denn wirklich so
einfach zahlen
der Staat wie gesagt hat
rekordsteuereinnahmen bei einer
stagnierenden Wirtschaft hat der allein
der Bund in diesem Jahr knapp fünf
Prozent mehr Steuereinnahmen durch den
Mechanismus den ich eben beschrieben
habe dass wir natürlich alle mehr
Steuern zahlen wenn die Preise steigen
jetzt kommt der Einwand viele Kommunen
können das nicht viele Kommunen sind
überschuldet das ist richtig aber die
Kommunen sind meistens schon seit 20 25
Jahren verschuldet und also das jetzt
den Beschäftigten zu sagen ihr müsst
jetzt auch noch für die Probleme der
Kommunen aufkommen halte ich für falsch
hier wurde vor einigen Wochen letztlich
der Bund und die Länder sind gescheitert
ihren Kommunen besser und die die Arme
zu greifen Bande bei der
Bewerkstelligung der Kosten für
geflüchtete und auch für die
Energiekrise also das geht ist da beim
Start ist es eine Frage ist dort zu
mobilisieren wo es benötigt wird
aber zum Beispiel der deutsche Städte
und Gemeindebund am Ende haben dann die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger den Nachteil weil
dann zum Beispiel die Schwimmbäder
teurer werden die Müll
Beseitigungskosten steigen die Schulen
nicht saniert werden können ist das für
sie ein Argument
dass manche Sachen teurer werden auch
bei den öffentlichen Dienstleistungen
verstehe ich das glaube ich muss auch so
sein da muss man sehr vorsichtig auch
sozial abwägen jetzt mehr kosten mehr
Geld für für Bildung einzunehmen würde
ich für ein Fehler halten da sollte der
Staat wirklich ein Vorleistung gehen
aber nochmals es geht darum dass der
Staat seinen Aufgaben nachkommt und
jetzt fehlende Sanierung von Schulen dem
Streik anzulassen halt die wirklich für
Protest denn man muss ja ehrlich sagen
die Schulen sind nicht erst alleine oder
zwei Jahren war oder sondern seit 20
oder 30
wie schätzen Sie die wirtschaftlichen
Folgen dieses Warnstreiks heute ein
die wirtschaftlichen Folgen natürlich
verursachte es einen gewissen schaden
aber ich halte den für sehr sehr gering
denn zum einen konnten sich viele darauf
einrichten zum zweiten
können viel mehr Menschen heute um
Office arbeiten also der Schaden ist da
aber wird gering bleiben es wird
wahrscheinlich nach oder Effekte geben
der Schaden entsteht dann wenn solche
Streiks eben für längere Zeit anhalten
dann könnte ich schädlich werden für
einzelne Unternehmer aber jetzt mit
diesem einen Tag sehe ich nicht dass man
hier von erheblichen Schaden sprechen
kann jetzt sagt der Kollege Michael
Hütter vom Institut der deutschen
Wirtschaft das beide Seiten sich nicht
überfordern dürfen weil sonst am Ende
gar nichts darum kommt würden sie das so
unterschreiben ist das eine
Überforderung die Forderung
ich halte 10,5 Prozent wie gesagt aus
den Eden erklärten Gründen bei einer
preisentwertung von 14 Prozent über die
zwei Jahre für nicht überzogen man muss
auch sehen dass auch Lohnsteigerung und
deutliche Lohnsteigerungen Vorteile für
Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft als Ganzes
haben wenn Menschen mit geringen
Einkommen entlastet werden stärkere
Lohnerhöhung bekommen können Sie auch
Ihre Nachfrage aufrechterhalten also
können Dinge einkaufen das ist wiederum
gut für die Unternehmen auch die
Kommunen auch der öffentliche Dienst
klagt bitter über ein Fachkräftemangel
naja der Fachkräftemangel wird nicht
besser wenn man eben nicht bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen anbietet wenn man
höhere Löhne anbietet also auch hier
höhere Löhne können helfen ein Teil der
stillen Reserve in unserem Arbeitsmarkt
also sprich das Menschen arbeiten oder
die Teilzeit arbeiten der Stunden
arbeiten kann man diese stille Reserve
ein wenig heben also man sollte nicht
nur das Schlechte von Lohnerhöhung sehen
sondern eben auch das was diese
Lohnerhöhungen für die Gesellschaft und
für die Wirtschaft als Ganzes Beit sagen
können ja es geht um Ausgewogenheit
nochmals wenn jetzt die Forderung 20 25
Prozent wären dann würde ich sagen das
ist jenseits von gut und böse aber mit
den Forderungen die jetzt im Raum stehen
die halte ich nicht für überzogen und
wir sehen ja auch bei vergangenen
Abschlüssen das auch die Beschäftigten
durchaus Maß und Mitte hatten dass
erwarte ich auch in dieser Runde
vielleicht zum Schluss noch ein
Kommentar von Marion auf Facebook sie
schreibt ich bin auch alt genug um mich
an die Zeiten zu erinnern als sie
beschäftigten bei der Bahn und bei der
Post noch verbeamtet Waren zuverlässig
pünktlich gut bezahlt nicht immer ist
Privatisierung positiv was sagen sie
dazu
ja die Deutsche Bahn ist ja nicht
privatisiert Züge gehört im Staaten und
ich glaube das zeigt dir das wo das
Problem ist nicht das ähm irgendwas
privat oder staatlich ist sondern hier
wurde viel zu lange viel zu lange über
Jahrzehnte am falschen Ende gespart
nämlich an der Infrastruktur also dass
der Staat nicht genug Geld ausgegeben
hat und den Fehler sollte die Politik
jetzt beheben wir brauchen mehr
öffentliche Investitionen und der Staat
muss auch seine Beschäftigten ordentlich
bezahlen also beides kommt zusammen aber
nochmals die Probleme die wir heute
haben beim öffentlichen Verkehr im
Verkehr allgemein das ist der Fehler der
Politik der letzten zwei bis drei
Jahrzehnte dass man von der Substanz
gelebt hat und im falschen Ende gespart
hat
dann möchte ich mich damit ganz herzlich
bei ihnen verdanken wir danken vielen
Dank Marcel Fratscher vom DHL
ja und jetzt wollen wir noch mal ganz
praktische Fragen zu dem Streit
beantworten und Fragen dazu die
arbeitsrechtlerin Lena Rutkowski
einen schönen guten Morgen ja Frau
Rutkowski 350.000 Beschäftigte sind
aufgerufen 24 Stunden lang zu streiken
wir hören heute morgen von der EVG dass
schon etwa 30.000 Beschäftigte an den
Standorten sich bis jetzt an dem Streit
beteiligt haben ist das aus ihrer Sicht
angemessen
ja wir haben die das Streikrecht als
grundrechtsausübung und da muss man
sagen wir haben eine sehr Streik
rechtsfreundliche Rechtsordnung und da
muss man das dann eben hinnehmen nach
gegenwärtiger Rechtslage das eben auch
mal einen Tag in Betrieben der
Daseinsvorsorge gestreikt wird und dann
eben auch Leistungen ausfallen die für
viele menschenlebenswichtig sind oder
konzentrale Bedeutung sind wir ein
Alltag
aber eigentlich schon von einem
Generalstreik sprechen wenn der
Verkehrsbereich in Deutschland so gut
wie lahmgelegt ist also kann man das
eigentlich noch warm Streik nennen
der Generalstreik ist der defizition
nach was anderes da würde man dann
darauf schauen ob wirklich alles lahm
liegt also auch außerhalb des
Verkehrssektors aber es ist natürlich
ein eindrucksvoller Streit den wir so in
den letzten Jahren nicht gehabt haben
und dann wollen wir jetzt noch mal ganz
praktische Fragen abarbeiten Kati fragt
auf Youtube kann ich abgemahnt werden
wenn ich es nicht zur Arbeit schaffe da
die Bahn nicht fährt
das ist grundsätzlich eine
arbeitsvertragspflichtverletzung sie
müssen erscheinen als Arbeitnehmer zur
Arbeit und sie haben auch das sogenannte
wege-risiko das heißt Sie müssen
irgendwie schauen dass sie zur Arbeit
kommen egal wie deswegen
sinnvollsten frühzeitig Bescheid sagen
und einfach mit dem Arbeitgeber sprechen
damit er dann auch Verständnis hat und
eben keine lohnausfälle drohen und keine
arbeitsrechtlichen folgen
dann fragt P auf Youtube wie wäre es
denn mal das Streikrecht zumindest in
der kritischen Infrastruktur
einzuschränken wie soll denn der Umstieg
auf die Öffis gelingen wenn die so
unzuverlässig sind
bei mir offene ich bin eigentlich wäre
ein großer Freund einer gesetzlichen
Regelung wir müssen aber
realistischerweise sagen nur die letzten
Jahrzehnte hat der Gesetzgeber das
Streikrecht nicht regeln wollen das ist
ein politisch sehr heikles Thema und da
ist jetzt auch nicht zu erwarten dass
sich das innerhalb der nächsten Jahre
realistischerweise ändern wird ich habe
noch mal hier eine Nachfrage zur
Anwesenheitspflicht entsteht an solchen
Tagen wie heute ein Recht auf Homeoffice
fragt paulinio oder kann ich zur
Anwesenheit im Büro gezwungen werden
sie können grundsätzlich zur Anwesenheit
im Büro gezwungen werden das ist ja ihre
Arbeitspflicht also je nach
Arbeitsvertrag ist es Ihre
Arbeitspflicht im Büro zu erscheinen und
wenn das laut Arbeitsvertrag eben drin
ist dann müssen sie erscheinen und
fragen wir jetzt noch mal nach den
Bahnreisenden wie sieht's da aus
bekommen die ihr Geld zurück
die Bahn hatte sich schon im Voraus
festgelegt also jetzt ganz unabhängig
von der Rechtslage dass sie da also
erstatten möchte das ist auch teilweise
so von der Fahrgastrechte Verordnung der
Europäischen Union vorgegeben dass bei
Zug Ausfällen die Fahrpreise zu
erstatten sind problematisch
muss man schauen ist
wir haben noch gar nicht auf die
Flugreisenden geschaut die sind ja heute
auch betroffen was müssen die wissen was
müssen die beachten
auch da gibt es grundsätzlich
Entschädigung nach der EU
fluggastrechteverordnung da gibt es dann
also Geld zurück okay Iris schreibt auf
Facebook man darf einem Streik nicht auf
den Rücken vieler unschuldiger Menschen
austragen die dann dafür den
finanziellen Schaden haben trifft dann
auch nicht auf alle zu Frau Rutkowski
vielleicht noch zum Schluss die Frage
dadurch dass das ja so ein riesen Streik
ist den es wirklich seit seit vielen
Jahren nicht mehr gab sehen sie darin
den Auftakt einer neuen Streitkultur in
Deutschland also wenn wir sowas in
Zukunft öfter erleben was dann
vielleicht so eskaliert wie die streikt
sie gerade in Frankreich sehen
ja das ist wie in Frankreich sehen das
wäre in Deutschland eindeutig unzulässig
das ist ein sogenannter politischer
Streik das heißt dort wird für eine
politische Forderung gestreikt gegen den
Gesetzgeber das geht in Deutschland ganz
klar nicht das wäre rechtswidrig und so
müssen wir uns in dem Bereich keine
Sorgen machen
damit vielen Dank Lena wokowski ich
danke Ihnen für Ihre Informationen
wünsche noch einen schönen Tag tschüss
ja und wenn ihr noch ganz praktische
Antworten zu diesem großen Warnstreik
heute braucht haben wir alles
zusammengefasst auf ZDF heute.de und
damit schalten wir dann noch mal kurz
Richtung Essen zu unserem Reporter
Thomas münten der auf einer Brücke über
der A40 steht Thomas ich sehe ähm so
langsam kommt es bei dir im Hintergrund
zum Stehen vorhin noch gerollt vor 25
Minuten aber jetzt so langsam geht gar
nichts mehr
ich habe mir gerade mal die
stauvorhersagen vom örtlichen Radio hier
angeschaut nein jetzt geht gar nichts
mehr jetzt steht der quasi wer hier im
Stau steht der steht im Stau von
Duisburg bis Dortmund und in das ganze
in dem Tempo also so richtig schön wird
das hier nicht und vor allen Dingen das
ist ja jetzt heute nur die hinstrecke
heute morgen und heute Abend haben wir
das ganze dann auf der anderen Richtung
wieder zurück das sorgt natürlich nicht
wirklich für Begeisterung und ähm du
konntest heute morgen mit ein paar
Leuten sprechen darüber mal kurz rein
ich habe einer dieses wichtig und ähm
aber andersrum ist er zu arbeiten wir
müssen alle Kollegen jetzt abholen sonst
die können nicht zur Arbeit kommen jetzt
einzelner Kollege müssen Verständnis
ja normalerweise schön aber nicht
ständig ne
ja also grundsätzlich Verständnis aber
nicht so oft vielen Dank Thomas münden
nach Essen mach's gut tschüss
gerne ja und damit verabschieden wir uns
auch für heute morgen bei euch wir
wünschen euch dass ihr gut ankommt wo
auch immer ihr hin müsst und wünschen
Euch eine gute Woche bis dann tschüss